what the hell hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Ben and
Ed um yeah anyway I didn't plan to start
the episode like this but here we go so
sorry for the delay on this one but we
entered one hell of a drug trip here
hello hi buddy how's it going yeah
that's what I figured you'd be doing uh
huh just oh don't be shy okay alright
then why you know I mean I'm pretty sure
the first two episodes of this video
we're just all me saying why as loud as
I could because I have no goddamn idea
why any of this is even remotely
possible let alone happening but also
the fact that everything is absurd how
did I get through this again for you a
button no [ __ ] me okay taking this again
and not hitting the reset button like a
big dumb goober who's too stupid to be
playing games and oh that's what I need
to do why are there 19 cans of meat on
this level look what is high oh you're
lovely
I don't want to say you're horribly ugly
because I would go on a tirade about how
that is true play with me forever I
don't know if I want to I don't even
know if I want to play in this nightmare
land forever we I was broke the game
again don't mind me
hellowho yes I have all my pieces I
don't know if I'm in a wall I don't know
if I'm gonna have them at the end of
this area hey okay
almost got sliced to bits by that but
everything was hunky-dory
yeah but ever care but Abba Dabba Dabba
Dabba ha badoo badoo don't know why I
needed to be in here I guess I'm pretty
sure I need the bonus meat to be able to
progress a little farther and a [ __ ]
game god dammit dammit it's the son of a
[ __ ] in city can bear [ __ ] you okay I'm
gonna kick the [ __ ] god damn it my god
screw you I'm not gonna hobble around on
my hands knees like an animal not that
I'd [ __ ] I can do this I'm not gonna
stumble by just with my head piece left
I'm gonna take my time see the
surroundings I want the correct way
thank you thank you
and then there's another way around back
here to get some special stuff it's not
gonna be a problem there's another
secret over here where do you go is this
actually a secret or is this just me
waiting it was me wasting everybody's
time okay wandering off you can't be me
I'm too good at the game sorry about
your loss oh god oh lordy okay I was
fine everything was fine until I
panicked
everything else in my life ever was
ruined by me panicking and I'll never be
as good as that was the first time when
I'm flying by blind luck and pure hatred
I do so much better than any other
opportunity that I have to succeed
[ __ ] [ __ ] see I didn't find the first
time why is it magically bad after I
fail okay so far so good
okay if I just don't panic I'll be
totally fine or if I don't try to for
some reason oh I didn't see
and it's hardly fair Oh mocking me for
my compounding failures that's been
doing that for four years now love you
guys but oh man you're a merciless when
I am terrible press the restart button
there's a goddamn mistake [ __ ] in the
butt okay we're fine
oh man it's aggravating when things go
horribly it's aggravating when things
you're horribly wrong for me it's not
that I'm doing it intentionally I hate
that I have to defend myself [ __ ] Oh
eat up bag of asses oh well thank you
for punching me right in my sternum oh
thank you for punching me right man [ __ ]
you this stupid camera wasn't my fault
my dad works at the place and made this
controller I don't know where oh alright
hang on here we go here we go
I wish this camera was a little bit
smarter than it is you know I wish I
wish I was a little bit smarter than I
am
because I keep doing stuff like that on
the first what the [ __ ] there we go
do the thing with the jumping would be
not [ __ ] you to such a bag of dicks what
a load of ass come on
okay there we go got it now okay cameras
gonna stay evenly
there we go easy enough that's gonna cut
my it off yep yep hope and like that
we're all in one piece let's go let's go
let's go
that's not waste a goddamn second let's
go okay is there anything else is gonna
happen friends man the guy who made this
whole dev devious labyrinth of mazes and
traps is any Gatiss to go faster that's
for sure
this giant busts of him thrusting at you
from the darkness now I'm not much what
I'm not much for darkness thrusting but
that's just something that I can't stand
for hope there we go what's up there
[ __ ] oh god that scared the crap out of
me oh my god I did so good up at that
point I wanted to find out what the hell
was on the secret platform and that is a
secret platform am I not right I am a
hundred percent right on that am i what
yes it is a secret platform wait where
do you go up here
wow what a bag of ass come on I get up
on the secret platforming not even gonna
give a [ __ ] but piss budget douche
nozzle this
come on the timings all off [ __ ] my
timings and my landing is all off [ __ ]
my timing in my arm and my landing are
all off even give me my timings off my
legs are off my arms are off my brain is
being turned off slowly by the agony of
fog you know I don't see how those
blades are actually slicing me into
because seems rather precarious oh wow
what the whoa way okay that was just
good dodging I'm really proud of myself
for doing that I am an expert at
whatever the hell is happening oh that
was a little too close so I did that
that's the thing that I did and then
proud of that I missed three meats but
it was levered relatively okay all right
next one ego hi how are you doing you
doing good you having a fun time
because I certainly am NOT even though I
kind of am this game is really cool by
the way well I was closed in the face
I'm closer to my grundle what are you
doing over there
cameraman come on it was barely a giant
ball in the face oh come on
yes I'm the best okay
well alright then quite stick the purge
oh come on
I had my pieces but had my pieces oh
come on I'm gonna stir here I can't even
get my golden idol Moon Baba I was doing
fine it's not my fault I landed wrong
here we go whoa okay we're fine not good
not good
okay whoa all right we're fine
everything's fine even though he's going
rather terribly yeah no I get over there
hi I jump
that's how oh don't do that don't do
that where does this go do I even want
to know Olga oh man
that's definitely a secret area but I'm
not gonna be able to get around this mi
oh yeah whoa that was not the correctly
whoops oh come on
Wow good job there buddy
Wow good job again you're gonna get
sliced you're gonna fall really you're
not gonna get up from man you could have
gotten up you lazy sack of crap all
right we're screwed screw this screw the
meat I'm just gonna fall in this guy's
mouth
that's all I really want to do and I'm
gonna do it gent I'm not gonna do a
gentle Emma oh you sack of [ __ ] oh you
titty sprinkle [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] yeah
okay what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you
he's in [ __ ] fury ating it's piece of
[ __ ] I didn't want to start off this day
like this why'd you tumble when you have
the choice of beans not stupid and being
stable on the platform why would you
choose to take a nosedive into the abyss
of nothingness and failure is that
because that's all you are and all you
ever will be is just God to [ __ ] you and
your [ __ ] eye you piece of crap I'll
[ __ ] off this game is goddamn
infuriating
[ __ ] off oh [ __ ] you okay let's just go
in the goddamn hole shan't we why didn't
I just go in the goddamn hole when I had
the opportunity why didn't I just jump
in the goddamn a hole from the get-go
there got it got the checkpoint with the
golden idol [ __ ] me I couldn't were just
reattached to my body but I didn't feel
like [ __ ] I didn't feel like it [ __ ]
me [ __ ] yeah that's right you don't
touch me I'm in touchable dicks all of
you everyone of you oh that was my fault
that was my fault I take credible
responsibility for things that are my
fault
but you know I just want everyone to
know how much [ __ ] everything else
is that just happened to me because that
was my fault but everything up until
that point was the game just being ass
bagman [ __ ] you yeah I don't know what
what is this I don't know how I'd do
this I don't do it wrong oh boy level
line took a turn for live the literal
literally oh it's a bag of asses forever
I saw bag of ass is this one of them Oh
Oh No
okay oh this is tricky everything's fine
everything's fine everything is okay
everything is okay oh yeah okay we're
fine we're fine we're fine we're fine
everything is fine everything is and
there we go okay we made it up
just one last trick cuz it knew that
markiplier was playing this and I could
be tripped up on the tiniest thing Oh
indeed I know this level looks like oh
you mean I gotta have patience this is
ridiculous how am I gonna woah I'm below
[ __ ] your [ __ ] god damn it you know [ __ ]
it I don't care
ha we're fine we're fine we're not going
that way cuz we're fine
we are frickin fine Oh God ha ha I'm not
gonna not gonna die oh no I didn't make
it apparently okay so that's the end of
this episode of pendant head I'm going
to play more of this game and I'm gonna
do with my sanity intact hopefully so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
oh wait are you guys that jumped up no
you